are you following this story on what's
going on with sri lanka what are your
thoughts on what's going on there uh
social breakdown is almost inevitable un
unless some miracle happens because the
president and
and his
flunkies have all fled they're on a boat
somewhere out in the ocean
and the people are occupying his his
palace
but i don't think there's any leadership
there now they don't have the fertilizer
they need to grow their food and sri
lanka is a very big food producing
country there's a lot of millions of
people there
and so this is the first bellwether of
the self-suicide destruction of these
elites
who i don't know where they get this
idea that there's too much nitrogen
in the soil or in the water uh nitrogen
is is again one of the building blocks
of life
and and just like with carbon dioxide
and so you you've got now netherlands
the
the president or prime minister whatever
he is of netherlands
is saying they have to have make make a
third of their animals go away
uh which provides a lot of the manure
for fertilizing the crops and then they
are also going to ban part of the
nitrogen fertilizer for the crops and as
i mentioned earlier
that the process of making synthetic
ammonia is why
there are many more billions of people
alive today than there would have been
if that hadn't happened it those two
nobel prizes that were given to dr haber
and bosch haber invented the process and
bosch
built it up to an industrial scale so
millions of tons
of fertilizer could be produced around
the world and all farmers in the world
are dependent on this fertilizer for
making their crops grow faster and and
bigger
and so if this if this cascades like
netherlands is getting a little close to
home it's happening in western europe
that leaders of governments are banning
fertilizer
and
as i say uh core blund has as a great uh
country singer in canada has a song
about
have you ever seen a a
a child who hasn't eaten in 18 days
and uh
you know we can live without food for
longer than we can without water and we
can live without water long longer than
we can without air
but there is a limit with food too and
mass starvation is not a pretty thing
and it's happened all through human
history we haven't had much of it lately
because we've been on a roll
in terms of uh technology and
agricultural innovation and producing
more food and doubled the population
like we see
but that doesn't necessarily go on
forever and it would be a shame if it
was a self-inflicted wound
uh oh it's okay okay
let's no let's at least not shoot
ourselves in in in the midsection here
uh that's what i see happening and
food shortages are not something that
are easily caught up with there are such
things as seasons
and there are such things as
how much you can grow in a certain area
of land and if you don't have fertilizer
you're only going to get half as much
and pretty soon the store shelves are
going to start being empty in some parts
of the world and hopefully we're
we're we're in a much better position in
north america than
most other places in the world in many
ways
but
this can come this can happen anywhere
if if people start deciding to ban
carbon dioxide and nitrogen which are
what life is made from
you know it's crazy i i when i saw this
i i wrote this out on twit on twitter i
said if the world allows a country with
a 81 billion gdp go bankrupt so can
america allow the too big to fail
companies fail soon bad policies created
by bad leaders caused countries to go
bankrupt the people of sri lanka were
sick of gotobaya rajapaska's democratic
socialist policies and they moved on
right they're saying they don't like it
now here's what's crazy
a guy responds back to this tweet and he
says
he says you're not going to find it but
if you go you'll find it because there's
a bunch of them to go through he says
well that has nothing to do with their
democratic socialist policies and then
one guy responds that's a great thing
about twitter when people have a debate
they're going to solve each other's
issues he says i'm sorry what do you
mean he says that's not has nothing to
do with democratic socialist policies
can you go to sri lanka's uh wikipedia
please go to sri lanka's wikipedia what
does it say on the top right
democratic to the top right right right
democratic rights republicans can you go
to the right yeah democratic socialist
republic of sri lanka that's long hand
for communism yes that's exactly it
folks if you hear
anybody in america pitch that to you and
they seem noble
eventually you'll be doing that 5 10 15
years later realizing that whoa that
vote was a shitty vote just like right
now we're facing some consequences with
inflation just came out yesterday being
nine point one percent inflation came
out yesterday nine point one percent you
know what inflation was in december of
2020 do you know what inflation was at
december of 20.
no no it was 1.4 1.7
okay if you pull up right now was on the
article inflation
just two years ago
december of 2020. you can actually look
this up it was 1.4
okay i was off by 0.2
then it went up to 1.7 then 4.2 then 5.4
the month that putin invades ukraine it
was 7.9 which means they can't blame
putin even pre-putin it was at 7.9 now
it's 9.1
inflation and uh who pays the price for
this do the billionaires pay the price
for this no do the rich pay the price
for this no who pays the price for this
the worst low-income middle-income
families who are going out there working
a job making 15 20 30 bucks an hour
trying to take care of their families
and they're paying a price for this
because they're filling in in the gas
station they're filling it everywhere
now biden sent a tweet out yesterday
responding to inflation i don't know if
you have that one up or not if you do
real quick this is what biden said after
the inflation numbers came up he said if
you can zoom in a little bit more uh
energy companies nearly half of today's
inflation numbers so here's what's
important energy loan comprises nearly
half of today's inflation numbers the
price of gas has increased 30 days
straight decreased decreased i'm sorry
decreased 30 days straight the price at
the pump has dropped by 40 cents since
mid-june
gas should continue to come down
in the days and work weeks ahead here's
a crazy thing here's a crazy thing
he's the president can you go back to
that tweet
a president sends a tweet and he gets 17
000
likes
this is not a tick tocker
this is the president that got 17 000
you know what 17 800 likes
that's like you putting the tweet and
you get two likes
i got over 3 000 uh
retweets just the other day and i've got
you're not the president i guess 2500
today this guy's the president
and can you go to the other one about
inflation go to the other one about
inflation that we got today's uh report
is uh inflation too high yeah uh
fighting inflation is my top economic
priority and while the numbers today are
not acceptable they're also outdated in
the past 30 years the average price of
gas is okay so he's trying to put that
message into 30 000 likes on that so
that's
making some progress it's like i'm
telling you do you know what this
reminds me of
where is will ferrell when he was making
fun of bush will ferrell how come you're
not doing it with biden biting is a
hundred times easier to make fun of than
when you were making part of bush when
he came out and said you and president
bush you know
i'm here in crawford texas growing my
soul patch hanging out with connie and
dick but we're keeping our eyes on the
ball and and we're we're
we're focused on climate change and bc
the rays are intensifying in such a way
where the lava flows in in in his cut
i'm not gonna lie to you i don't know
what the hell i'm talking about i mean
let
the boy
watch is what you're trying to say right
now what i'm trying to say is will
ferrell come on man come on
fair and do a joe biden impersonation
be better than
uh the bush impersonation so if you like
this clip and you want to watch another
one click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
[Music]